good morning John it's Wednesday it's
song Wednesday the Wednesday before the
project for awesome and yesterday you
made a video about things that you love
and I was gonna play this song today but
that video inspired me to play a song
about something that I love and it's a
little bit more sentimental than my
average song but it is about love so
hopefully you'll like this despite the
fact that it isn't my usual fare the
song is for a girl no wait I changed my
mind this song is for an adult female
is it just me or creepy how often pet
names refer to little children
and it's not just girl and it's not just
maybe it's also boy and I think it's
where we get shoddy
so this song is for the adult female
line and if there's anything that
been dreaming up
while she you have to do is ask
yeah she wants me to I'll do whatever
she asks me to do as long as
really
or otherwise makes me uncomfortable
cuz that's what love is and I have been
border
this songs about love but not what we
think of as love is special if we are
Justin Bieber
love is heart and love is messianic and
hurt worse than firing sometimes and if
you want to tear down a building with
your bare hands but it also happens to
be the best thing that's ever happened
obviously and a big fan of hyperbole
so this song is for the adult female on
and if there's anything that she's been
dreaming and if I can acquire it with
the amount of money I have without
making myself destitute then all she
have to do is ask and I'll be with her
until the end of time as long as time
before one of us dies
cuz that's what love is and I have
before yeah that's what uh and I have it
boy
oh that's what love is and I have before
I love you baby I hope you didn't find
that too corny and all that I have up to
say is youtube.com slash p4a if you
haven't subscribed seriously you're
going to regret it end screen time click
on the project for awesome logo if you
haven't subscribed go subscribe I also
put some links to some of my old songs
up here and of course you can always go
see me kill people in Assassin's Creed
sometimes I sing songs while I'm killing
people in Assassin's Creed like die die
die die die die die die die die die die
stab stab